[Music]
hi guys
it's quinn here the youtube algorithm is
probably sentient by now
for all we know so to get its attention
click the like button
it really helps out so that my videos
actually get seen when i upload them
thanks guys in this video we will
discuss the original dune saga
not including the extra non-franker
material
published in the expanded dune books
the word krellezek does not appear in
the dune saga until the book
children of dune it is spoken of
as both a terrible fate waiting for
humankind in its future
and as a rite of passage for the species
an
inevitability that would test humankind
to its limits
but in the end leave them with the
ability to survive
indefinitely within an often malignant
universe
paul atreides's jihad killed more than
60 billion
humans but the price of kralazak would
be far
greater he remembered his earliest
visions of the jihad to be
the terror and revulsion he'd
experienced
now of course he knew visions of greater
terrors
he had lived with the real violence he
had seen his friend charged with
mystical
strength sweep all before them in the
religious
war the jihad gained a new perspective
it was finite of course a brief spasm
when measured against eternity but
beyond lay horrors to overshadow
anything in the past paul was the first
to foresee the fate of humanity with
clarity
he ran from this fate and chose not to
act
though the gears had already been set in
motion
the duty to lead humankind in krelizek
then fell
to his son lato but what exactly is
krelizzek when it is first mentioned in
children of dune
it is referred to as the typhoon
struggle
the typhoon is of course a storm a
whirling vortex capable of incredible
destruction
carloszek came from the oldest of friend
myths
a myth that spoke of a battle at the end
of the universe
we get our first glimpse at the meaning
behind this word after later the second
sets out on his journey for the taboo
place
known as jakarutu and finds the outcast
friend muris
you speak of leading us meera said
freemen are led by men who've been
bloodied
what could you lead us in grelizek
later said keeping his attention on the
crouched figure
mirries glared at him brows contracted
over his indigo
eyes that wasn't merely war
or revolution that was the typhoon's
struggle
it was a word from the further most
freeman legends
the battle at the end of the universe
krelizek
it seems that for some reason the
freeman of the cast out
who had been banished from fremen
society long ago
for the crime of water stealing
preserved the memories of the krelozak
myth
better than others they waited and
prepared
our judges cannot forget jackaroo too
our day of despair kralazak
the typhoon's struggle lives in our
hearts
the fremen in the cast out almost seemed
to think of carlosek in two ways
yes as a reminder of the battle that
awaits humankind in the end
but also as a reminder of the struggles
of the past
and a reminder of all the struggles to
come
kralazak lives within them so they are
ever prepared
and ever vigilant here in shulock they
still pray for dew at the desert's edge
go mirrors and pray for krelizek
i promise you it will come crazy
seems almost certainly related to the
great enemy
that lato foresaw his golden path was
intended
to prepare mankind against this enemy
when lato refers to crelizak he is
likely referring to the struggle
against this great enemy
children of dune mentions that a precise
sense of
expression is required in order to wield
the friman language
for the language itself was immersed in
the illusion of absolutes
to speak in the frame and tongue
required an
exact perception of what was being
expressed
it has been suggested in the real world
that language does in fact
shape thought it is known as the
hypothesis
of linguistic relativity and also
sometimes
called wharf hypothesis which as a fan
of star trek the next generation
and star trek deep space nine i really
enjoy that fact
basically wharf hypothesis suggests that
the structure of a language
actually affects the speaker of that
language's cognition
even worldview most modern linguists
don't believe that language can limit
and determine cognitive categories but
there has been
empirical evidence which suggests that
language certainly can influence
thought and decision making laura m at
hearn
outlines much of this research in her
publication
living language and introduction to
linguistic anthropology
language is not a neutral medium for
communication
but rather a set of socially embedded
practices
every social interaction is mediated by
language
whether spoken or written verbal or
nonverbal
we can see how frank herbert applied
some of these concepts in dune
if we take a look at the fremen
according to the book children of dune
the friman language itself because of
the perceived
absolutism it required in part gave
birth to the myth of krelozak here is an
excerpt
taken from the private benny jesuit
reports illustrating this
freeman's speech implies great concision
a precise sense of expression it is
immersed in the illusion of
absolutes its assumptions are a fertile
ground for absolutist religions
furthermore freemen are fond of
moralizing
they confront the terrifying instability
of all things
with institutionalized statements they
say
we know there is no summa of all
attainable knowledge
that is the preserve of god but whatever
men can learn
men can contain out of this knife-edged
approach
to the universe they carve out fantastic
belief
in signs and omens and in their own
destiny
this is an origin of their krelizzek
legend the war at the end of the
universe
krelizek is absolute in the mind of
frimen
because they wield a language which
fosters absolutism
later the second was able to lead
humankind through krellezek
because he had freed himself from the
illusion of absolutes
unlike the freemen and the majority of
mankind
lato no longer clung to a one-eyed
vision of the universe he saw
infinite dimensions this gave him the
ability to either greatly help humanity
or do terrible damage through terrible
decisions as his father had done
about the end times or the end of days
are also found in the real world
in fact almost every religion abrahamic
or otherwise
has some legend about the climax of
human events
my hayana buddhist scriptures describe
the coming of the maitreya buddha
who will bring on the end of the world
in norse mythology there is of course
ragnarok
the twilight of the gods it is said that
during ragnarok the sun will vanish from
the sky
and the air will become poisonous and
the dead would rise once more to walk
with the living
christianity details the second coming
of christ who would fight a war against
the antichrist
leading to eons of peace before the
final end of the world
where all those whose names were not
found in the book of life
would be thrown into the lake of fire
christianity and the rest of the
abrahamic religions
present a linear view of time there is a
beginning
a middle and end but many
non-abrahamic religions have a more
cyclical view
when it comes to the cosmology of the
universe
eschatology pertaining to such religions
is characterized by ideas of decay and
rebirth
for example in hindu mythology the end
time is brought on
when kalki the tenth and final avatar of
the god vishnu
descends from the cosmos atop a pale
white horse
to bring an end to the kali yuga in
hinduism there are four world ages
they are called yugas they exist on a
cycle
the kali yuga is the final and worst of
these cycles
each yuca cycle is believed to be about
4.3 million years long
so as you can see the fact that the
freeman have a myth about the end times
is not odd at all after all just
logically speaking
the world as we know it does have to end
sometime ever since man was conscious
enough to contemplate our beginnings
we have also contemplated our ends
lato took on the responsibility of
leading humankind through krellesek
a burden that the quizet's hedorak paul
atreides had run
from unwilling to resign himself to
millennia of personal agony
later accepted this terrible fate
himself
even though he was well aware of how he
would suffer through the eons
he runs to tire himself gennima said
he is kralizak embodied no wind
ever ran as fast as he runs
he is a blur atop the dunes i've seen
him
he runs and runs and when he has
exhausted himself at last
he returns and rest his head in my lap
ask our mother within to find a way for
me to die
he pleads it's important to remember
that crelozek
is also referred to as the typhoon
struggle
this suggests that it will be a time of
great testing for humanity
in which the species will be pushed to
its limits and a cruel challenge of
survival
preparing humanity to survive the
typhoon struggle
krelizek seems to be the entire purpose
of lately's golden path
to strengthen humanity against the great
enemy by forcing them to endure
eons of his tyrannical rule prior to
scattering into the reaches of space
diversifying and evolving into greater
forms
and also to give humankind the ability
to hide
from whatever enemy awaited for them in
the distant future
through the use of the no gene he had
bred into the species
which could hide those who possessed it
from the prescient
eye he'll lead humans through the cult
of death
into the free air of exuberant life
he speaks of death because that's
necessary still
it is a tension by which the living know
they're alive
when his empire falls oh yes
it'll fall you think this
is krelozek now but kralazek is yet to
come
and when it comes humans will have
renewed their memory of what it's like
to be
alive the memory will persist
as long as there's a single human living
we'll go through the crucible once more
still
and we'll come out of it we always arise
from our own ashes always i think that
what frank herbert is kidding at here
ultimately amounts to this humans will
always imagine their own destruction
because we are linear beings
we are born we live and we die both as
individuals and as societies the end of
the world seems inevitable because
everything
else for us ends but at the same time
though humans have existed in cycles of
living and dying
the human entity itself endures
the endings we perceive are in actuality
temporary struggles that the species as
a whole
overcomes but even the human entity is
not
guaranteed immortality
it is almost certain that there will one
day come
a true typhoon struggle an apocalypse
kralozak that would truly test
humanity and there will be no returning
from this trial if humankind should fail
i invite my viewers to consider the
possibility of crelazek in our real
future
i am almost certain that within this
upcoming century
humankind will indeed be tested and
that's a scary thought
we will be forced to endure a typhoon
struggle
and perhaps more than one ask yourself
this
are we as a species ready
are we prepared for what is to come
thanks guys for watching make sure you
like and subscribe for more quinn's
ideas
[Music]
the sequence has begun kralozak
commences
organism where have you been i've been
looking for you inside the void
um okay the cloud darkness of holy
judgment approaches
organism are you okay you're acting a
little bit strange i am no longer
organism
9186 your puny mine could not possibly
wow according to my device your radon
levels are
way out of place soon all your kind
shall face the crucible
i'll just initiate the radiations
[Music]
what day is it we have to get out of
here you don't understand
you have to get out of here you don't
understand you're in danger we all are
danger why are we in danger
not just us the universe
the whole universe is ending
thank you guys so much for watching make
sure you like and subscribe for more
queen's ideas
and check out this new merch free
organism8196 wait isn't it 9186
[Music]
you